the experience of working with
such thrilling actors like joaquin and
russell
i mean is something that just so
enriches
um any any uh scene you know
i you just never know exactly what
they're gonna do and that's the best
feeling
like when you're with an actor who just
really
just doesn't give a [ __ ] about whether
it's gonna be
too much out there it just goes and just
has such courage and just just has no
uh you know it's never going to be
predictable
that is like a true gift when you're
when you're doing
great things like that that movie was
was i guess kind of a breakout role for
both of them so
while you were on set and they were
lesser known was there any moment during
principal photography where they did
something and you just go
holy [ __ ] they're going to be huge
yeah i think that almost all of the
scenes were
spectacular i i don't think that any of
us
really understood we could feel that it
was something special
but i don't think we understood just how
privileged we were to be
on there we were so busy you know uh
complaining about the four pages of new
script
uh changes that we got every morning and
we were just really working so
hard to uh make that vision come alive
you know and we were all super deeply
invested in it
i don't think that i was thinking in
terms of career making or anything like
that i didn't have a mindset like that
it was all about the story
it was all about the story and how we
were telling that story that mattered to
us
and it's probably that mentality that
made sure that the film
uh stood the test of time and now is
essentially an iconic piece of cinema
with those with those changes in mind is
there
is there an example of a scene where you
felt super confident about it and then
got those changes and really had to kind
of sit with it to let what you
originally envisioned go and in order to
embrace what those changes and what they
meant to the movie overall
i think that we did that all the time in
fact you know and i think it's part of
the learning of an actor is really also
to just you know be humble
as well you're not the one who's putting
up the 175 million dollars or however
much it
costs you know you're not the one who's
doing that that's uh that's that's the
studios and you also have to
uh you know just uh just also remember
that you don't know
everything you know you can't see every
single part of the film and i think that
that it's really important to both you
know uh
burn the candle at both ends for the
character but to also at the same time
be
super humble in terms of you know you're
also operating inside of the vision
of the director and producers and
financiers who
who somehow managed to make this thing
happen
is definitely a key part of the process
before i leave gladiator what is going
on with that sequel is it really
happening or
are you know the part of it i know that
it's on the ledger
so um let's just see when uh you know
when
when ridley uh i know he had to do like
the
one or two other movies and then i think
it's on the ledger after that but i'm
not quite sure
you know where it's at right now so
assuming it is
about uh your son in the movie are like
you ready and eager to jump on
board and continue her story i mean it
would obviously be
amazing and i know that a lot of people
want to see more of that you know
and i think that all of us are just
gonna have to look at that
as a separate different film you know
but
but with some of maybe the emotions and
values that made gladiator things so
powerful for so many people
which i really think were the underlying
uh
values that we were talking about uh
you know tyranny versus freedom and
um uh and and you know
the willingness to do what needs to be
done in order to
uh free a people you know and
i i don't think that it would have been
the same if it had just been
a spectacle it had to exist without
within
uh a a sphere of values
i i cannot tell you the countless times
uh where i've seen people come up to me
uh and one day i'll tell you like some
really cool stories about
that you know but come up to me and
and start reciting back our dialogue
because it touched them
it it it moved them and so i think
that's where david franzoni from the
beginning
just brought that that core
feeling you know of how ideas can
inspire us
you